foreign
the piece has been unrelenting at this
emergency Distribution Center in
Istanbul these volunteers know time is
of the essence for their suffering
fellow Turks I have to be here I cannot
stay at home like it feels really awful
too like what's from like watch the news
from TV I just need to be here to help
the people
there is Unity resolve and an
understanding that this humanitarian
effort will take on historic proportions
it will also be costly president erdogan
has allocated more than 5 billion
dollars to help the country recover from
what could emerge to be the worst
natural disaster in two generations our
prayers are with them
our hopes are with them so we are
working with the volunteers with all our
strengths and is that people of Istanbul
never let us down with the solidarity
president erdogan has declared a
one-week period of national mourning and
schools have been closed
the current situation requires us to
take Extraordinary Measures we declare
our 10 provinces where the earthquake
took place as disaster zones we decided
to declare a state of emergency so that
the search and rescue activities and all
subsequent Works can be carried out
rapidly the seat of emergency will end
shortly before the presidential and
parliamentary elections scheduled on May
14th inflation in Turkey is 80 percent
and critics say government policy is
exacerbating the country's economic woes
the earthquake zone in southern turkey
is home to a significant Syrian refugee
population
right-wing parties are calling them a
burden on an already overtaxed economy
in the ruins of homes and amid the
morning of loved ones lost there is no
distinction between citizen or Refugee
just a human being in need of immediate
help and compassion Natasha ganim Al
Jazeera Istanbul